so let's get to the other news because
we're going to spend a lot of time
before we turn
to super bowl 55 on a blockbuster trade
that came out in nowhere
after 10 p.m eastern on saturday night
word was leaked and things like this get
leaked deliberately and the fact that it
was leaked when it was tells me it's not
a giant win-win otherwise they would
have saved it until today and taken over
the first day of super bowl week with
the news and the reaction to it
the trade that sends lions quarterback
matthew stafford
to the rams for
quarterback jared goff a first round
pick in 2022
a first round pick in 2023
a third round pick in 2021 i was blown
away by it i thought the reports that
the two
teams were talking were aimed at maybe
helping generate a trade market for
stafford help
goose it a little bit because brad
holmes worked for the rams
and it also was helping send the message
that the rams were done with golf but
there was no way they were gonna work
this out
they couldn't work it out not without a
first round pick this year not with
goff's gigantic cap number
and cash commitment no way would they
work it out and they did
they did and you know shocking but not
shocking i mean in some ways so saturday
morning mike
you know i'm texting with a few people
around the nfl and just catching up hey
what's up how's everything been you
enjoying the off season things like that
i did get word then that things had
gotten serious right that there was
going to be
you know something going down later on
today where
you know the the rams had found some
sort of partner or trade partner for
jared goff so i was kind of just oh okay
that's interesting i wonder who it'll be
and then you know we get the news on
saturday night blown away i mean really
that's the first thing i'll say
blown away just in the fact that i
didn't know if it actually would ever
happen
not blown away that it was the detroit
lions and that it actually
happened with them i mean you mentioned
it it's brad holmes there's some home
cooking involved here
with this deal all together but i'll say
this
i don't know mike i mean right off the
bat let's just hit this
are you you're shocked by the price tag
of what it took to get stafford there in
la
uh for for the trade no because
it wasn't just the price to get
stafford right right part of what the
rams paid
was to offload the golf contract you
know you hear two ones and a three
and and i saw someone tweeted the
question should one of the other teams
that
were in contention for matthew stafford
have offered two ones and a three
that misses the point you're not giving
up
two first round picks and a third round
pick to get stafford
you're you're getting two ones and a
three
for stafford plus inheriting a 43
million dollar fully guaranteed
commitment to a guy that the rams didn't
want this was the only way
the lions were getting this and this was
the only way
that the rams were avoiding a brock
osweiler type of a trade
because if you strip stafford away from
it and i was
texting with a gm yesterday morning like
how much of this was for stafford and
how much
of it was to take goff and we kind of
settled on a one and a three for
stafford
and the rams giving up the 2023 first
round pick to offload goff
that's what this deal was it was
right give us stafford and please
take goff off our books yeah it
certainly seems that way and then that's
where like
you know i know there was some initial
shock and jaw-dropping over like the
price tag
you know matt stafford he's never won a
playoff game you know you hear all that
type of talk
but the the the reality is is exactly
what you said
you got a player in matthew stafford
okay for
lack of a better way of saying this
who's twice as good as jared
goff for half the price so that is going
to drive up the value of the player
tremendously just because of that
i mean realistically matthew stafford is
a quarterback that dances around the top
10
in football you know you give him the
right support system he's really he's
got
greater he's he's a top 10 talent in
football that's what he is
and then he got a guy like jared goff
who you know
legitimately or at least in my eyes in
my
evaluations i think is towards the top
10 bottom 10
or 12 quarterbacks in football so then
when you look at it that way
plus the guy who's the lesser
quarterback is being paid
basically twice as much as the other guy
we're talking about that's a top 10
talent
that is going to drive up the price but
the rams don't give a damn they were
done with jared goff
they had their eyes set on matthew
stafford and they were going to do what
they needed to do to get
get get the job done and that's what i
at least respect about the rams
they're not a dip your toe in the water
type of football team that's for sure
when they like something they go for it
and they play it they play it aggressive
well yeah when they like something they
go for it like they did with jared goff
when they moved up to get him
when they did with jared goff when they
paid him before they should have paid
him they could have avoided this entire
mess
if they just hadn't paid him a 33.5
million
a year contract in 2019 when
you and i were saying don't do it
don't do it they did it two seasons
later
they give up even more to get him off
the books it's stunning to me that it
came to this as quickly as it did
and you know i was trying to understand
what kind of message they were sending
with these ambivalent at best statements
about jared goff from sean mcvay right
after the loss to the packers
in the playoffs the next day an even
more clear comment from mcveigh
that goth may not be on the team next
year
les snead the gm of the team and his
comments
from last week when he met with
reporters how about what in the world
are they trying to do here are they just
trying to give jared goff a hell of a
wake-up call
i think what they were trying to do was
get the fan base and the media that
covers the team
to to wrap their brains around the idea
this guy's gone
he's gone get ready he's gonna be gone
and i think it made it a little bit
easier for the fan base to say okay
well we're giving up a lot here for a
guy who's never won a playoff game and
has only been there three times and golf
has won three playoff games
the last three seasons two in 2018 one
in
2020 okay well let's go let's see what
we got here
and so yeah this thing was happening
because the rams were determined to make
it happen no matter the cost and that's
the key
without the stafford component they
would have had to have done a brock
osweiler type of a hot potato trade
and that would have been significantly
more embarrassing than when you look at
the final tally for what they gave up
to swap goff for stafford oh well i mean
it's amazing i mean honestly mike i
think the most fascinating part of the
whole trade the whole story is how
quickly it all fell apart between jared
goff and sean mcvay
it was always when do you think the
moment was what do you think it was
when was the moment that they were like
this is it he's done
i i i don't know if there's like a
moment moment to where it's just like
all of a sudden there was an epiphany or
anything like that
i've been thinking about this a lot
since the trade just because you know i
knew we were going to talk about it and
all of that
you know like a few things jump out so
maybe where i think this could have
changed you know
one like we talked about they made it a
huge investment
in a guy and one of the weakest links on
their starting 22
roster is the highest paid guy on the
football team that's not going to sit
well
with people in the locker room or of
course of course the coaches in the
organization
you know evaluating your own team is
always figuring out how is your money
performing
that's not helping but then i think one
this is the
the other two things mike that jumped
out to me yes
they had to manage the offense in a way
that
that helped jared goff right that you
know played to some of his strengths and
and his weaknesses they played an
offense that
you know didn't show them they could
hide them that way so i think that
got tiring for sean mcvay most likely
and then the other thing i look at too
is just
this year he became careless with the
football too
so hey wait now he doesn't make plays
and now
i can't even manage him anymore because
he's starting to be careless with the
football and
fumble throw dumb interceptions and big
moments of the football game and i think
that to me
would be like a sean mcvay type of coach
who came from john gruden
that would be my you know inner soul
deep dive look there to what i think
would happen but i don't know the
answers to that
it's uh it's very intriguing look at
that top
line you look at that passing percentage
7.8 for golf 37 folks there's still only
32 teams in the nfl in case you forgot
37th in the league with a deep passing
percentage of 7.8 and
you know chris to me this this
is a more complicated
and convoluted mirror image to the
brady belichick who was responsible for
what went well with the patriots all
those years
and and we're going to see it
interlocking and intertwining between
the rams and the lions because
as stafford leaves detroit we get a
chance to find
out whether or not the failure of the
past 12 years
was him or them and as goff leaves the
rams
for the lions we get to find out whether
or not the regression of the offense
because obviously the team hasn't been
horrible
they won in the wild card round this
year they lost to the number one seat at
lambeau field i mean what did we expect
did anybody think the rams were going to
go in there to actually win that game i
don't think so
but the offense has regressed is it
teams have caught up with sean mcvay or
is it jared goff was never all that good
so that's one of the things we're gonna
find out and look look at how the
offense has dipped
look at the scoring from first in 2017
to 22nd in 2020
unbelievable and look i think a big part
of it is todd gurley
he was the offensive player of the year
in 2017. sure it was late in 2018 when
that knee started to be a problem
and that's when the the greatest
show-offs on turf part
two started to lose their punch
they managed three points in the super
bowl in part because todd gurley was no
longer todd gurley
i think gurley had so much more to do
with the rise of that team than goff
definitely for the regression for the
regression though
is it that the passing game was just
never all that great without a guy like
goff to make it go
or is it defenses have caught up with
sean mcvay we're going to find out
pretty quickly well there's a little bit
of both but like kristen if you can
could you put that graphic back up there
too
because i think there's you know you
talk about the scoring but look at that
bottom line mike the turnovers it's just
a little bit of what we just talked
about
you know hey we can get to the super
bowl and be a playoff team with 13
11 you know in football and turnovers
whoa
22nd in turnovers wow no you better make
some plays to make up for all those
turnovers oh no you didn't we didn't
make the playoffs oh
25th this year in turnovers yeah i know
they made the playoffs
but it was a struggle offensively all
year they had to have the number one
defense in the game who made a lot of
plays and big moments
to help them win football games but but
mike you're right we're gonna see i mean
listen i think there's a little bit of
both here and that's what's amazing
about this trade there's just so much to
unpack here with
you know one the rams are fortunate yeah
that they found a team
that had a personnel guy a gm who
believed in jared goffstill to be a
starting quarterback
so that was a huge benefit for the rams
there's no doubt about that
now people catching up to the mcvay
offense and all of those type of things
yeah i do think that's true i i agree
with you there and i agree with your
todd gurley assessment
i mean we were saying when you were
banging the drum about why i paid jared
goff i know one of the things i was
saying was
i agree with you mike i don't understand
it's you know
hand the ball off todd gurley 20-yard
run you know fake the ball to todd
gurley throw him a screen and he ran for
40 yards
he was a very important part of that
football team but once he went away
that put more of the spotlight on weight
our running game is not as dominant hey
quarterback you might have to make a few
plays
for todd gurley whose knee's not the
right way and now not on the team
and that never happened and that to me
mike that's where matthew stafford is
going to really help the football team
he's going to be able to still run all
those same plays
but now he's going to have a more
aggressive mindset
and because he's a better thrower of the
football he's going to be a better
decision maker he'll be more aggressive
with throws down the field
and it's going to embolden sean mcvay to
open things up too with all these plays
too go
whoa my guy can do this whoa you know
the last guy i
had couldn't throw this route now i can
throw it with this guy
let me find some other cool things and i
think that's going to be the beauty of
the marriage between mcveigh and
stafford
so it's not just going to be slants and
bubble screens it's going to be ball
down the field to robert woods and
cooper cup that's what we're going to
see
i i would think so yes i i think you
know you're going to see a blend of what
we've always seen with the rams
but mcveigh's gonna have a new toy and
like i was talking about i mean
hey you joke about it all the time he's
kind of like a mini gruden
and i just i've been around a guy like
this when he gets a new toy
it becomes a lot of fun and let me try
this and who i never did this play
before
let me see if he can do it and i think
he's going to tinker and toy with a lot
of different plays and concepts in the
off season
just to help out his normal offense from
goff's perspective the environment
recently with the
rams was characterized to me as toxic
and that it is mcveigh desperate
because the league has caught up with
his offense and he needs to show
it wasn't him it was goff and and that's
a little bit of the gruden
influence right it's never sure the
coach
it's the quarterback and and i agree
with you there's going to be
an adrenaline rush for sean mcvay and
it'll be interesting to see how stafford
responds to that not just short term
but over the course of a full season at
what point has
did stafford say dude settle down i got
this no just
chill just hav just come on i know what
i'm doing i've been doing this for 12
years like like the relationship itself
we'll see how that works over the long
haul stafford's a different kind of guy
i don't mean that as a criticism he's
just always been a different kind of guy
shows up throws the football he's never
been keen on the rest of the trappings
of being an nfl franchise quarterback
you know i've said before
i think he doesn't want to be that
leader he doesn't want to embrace that
fool
peyton manning tom brady there's a new
sheriff in town reality
but he also didn't get and i'm trying to
think of the right word to use here
he you know the lions were bad for 12
years
and he was content for most of 12 years
to be part of a bad team
other quarterbacks would not tolerate
that they would say get me the hell
out of here long before 12 years in so
that's what i'm curious about how does
stafford's unique and i don't mean that
in a bad way we all have our own unique
personality he's got a unique
quarterback personality
how's that going to fit with mcveigh and
it's going to be great at first and it's
never going to be better than it is
as stafford walks through the door what
happens over time
how long does this last and he is going
to be 33 on sunday
so it's not like they have 15 years but
you know
they did great things in five years with
jared goff it just tailed off the last
two so maybe the first few
if cam akers continues his trajectory
upward
maybe he becomes kind of like todd
gurley maybe the offense opens up and
you still have aaron donald
and you still have jaylen ramsey you
know maybe the window's still open for
this team
but i think there's a ton of pressure on
mcvay to get this right and to show that
stafford is dramatically better than
goff
no i i don't disagree with you i i don't
and and
you know really ultimately when it comes
to that discussion i will be shocked if
it if it doesn't show that way
that the offense isn't improved and
mcvay
you know does have the ability to show
you oh hey no no we we were we were
handcuffed a little bit by the
quarterback situation we had here
not anymore and i think you're going to
see a different variety of plays and
offensive schemes i would be shocked
i really think the marriage in a lot of
ways is perfect mike
for a lot of the like the reasons you
said you kind of said it last week even
when you brought this up when we were
talking about stafford
yeah he might not be that rah-rah guy he
doesn't need to be on this team
he's got a psycho head coach who's a
rah-rah guy so that's where it really
fits well
now staffer can just kind of go play
football
and maybe we'll see more of that
demeanor
that you're talking about again i'll
always argue it's hard to be that guy
when you've been in this culture this
whole time of
no success no leader to show you
the right way to win a football game or
act he's never really had anything to
sit there to where you and i
can just tangibly go well he did have
this in detroit and that should have
taught him this
there's really none of that to speak of
so that's where i'm excited for matt
stafford
and what i do know about the situation
is
stafford was keen on making this happen
with sean mcvay
you and i know there was both a lot of
suitors for jerry
uh for for matthew stafford in the trade
market and there was teams that were
interested
i know he told a handful of teams no and
he was steering this
trade towards getting with mcveigh
there is some sort of personal
relationship there where he wanted to
play from him
i know that very clearly and that's
where
you know that helped out this trade as
well
here's what else is fascinating about
this because brad holmes
the new gm of the lions had just come
from the rams as one of the
right-hand men to les snead the gm brad
holmes the director of college scouting
he'd been with the team a long time so
he's in the middle of the bubble he sees
what's going on with goff
and he still wants goff which kind of
implies
that it wasn't goff right to take off
and to be happy about it and supposedly
they are happy about it we'll talk more
about the lions angle
of this coming up i'm trying to fold
this in from the perspective of the rams
that whatever the feeling was about golf
within the building it apparently wasn't
universal
because they did get a guy who had just
left the building
to take jared goff and and the planets
had to line up perfectly
on this they really did if stafford
wants the rams
the rams want to unload golf and oh look
we got lucky here
our former director of college scouting
ends up as the new general manager
of the detroit lions were able to make
this deal
happen and you know it's it's hard not
to wonder
and and this may be reading too much
into it but did the lions have an eye on
goff
when they hired brad holmes was that
part of the conversation
was that part of what got holmes the job
there was a shared vision that maybe
goff is the answer once they know
they're moving on
from matthew stafford chris i you know i
don't know and we never will know but
man it just is amazing how this
this lined up perfectly and it's not one
of those things where in hindsight i was
like wow this was the only deal that
could have been done
there are other deals that could have
been done but this is the only way
that you get stafford to a place where
he wants to go and you get goff out of
la in one transaction that
it isn't a bright red sign we failed we
failed we
failed we have to give someone net trade
value
to get rid of this guy no no i mean
that's what's amazing i mean one you
know brad holmes
uh i do think that was a great signing
by the detroit lions i really do
you know he's was in the he was with the
rams when they drafted jared goff so
this was a guy that he was in that front
office and most likely was a believer in
what golf can do
and will do in the future and all those
type of things you know that was the big
part of the trade yeah there was
obviously some home cooking here
we know there were some other teams
involved but
the the thing that was big here was you
had to have a team
that was willing to accept jared goff as
their starter
and to me that was the biggest wrench in
the whole
conversation and with brad holmes he
obviously believes in jared goff the
person the player
and then hey the detroit lions oh we got
draft picks now to go around
go along with us well brad holmes i mean
that's that's kind of what he does so he
wants to build through the draft and do
that
and it works out for the rams because
they seem to be anti
work through the draft let's just sign
star players that are proven commodities
and we'll build a team that way and
that's what really helped out this whole
thing as well
uh which was very unique and last thing
that i just find
a little unique because it popped into
my head and i meant to say it earlier
i do think it's funny that matt
stafford's going to la to like reunite
with his buddy clayton kershaw who he
went to high school with i think that's
kind of a cool fact too
yeah la by way of texas where they went
to the same high school the high school
that bobby lane went to and bobby lane
put the 50-year curse on the lions when
they traded him
that lasted 60 years and who knows maybe
it's going to extend beyond that
but you know this this is what i'm
really
fascinated by as it relates to the brad
holmes
less need dynamic the two gm's who did
this deal
like yeah
you always want to sell a trade is
win-win because you don't want teams to
not
trade with you you don't want to have a
reputation for always kicking the other
team's butt in a trade
or teams will shy away from being the
next one to get their butt kicked
but to me like this is
either less need thinking man i really
snookered brad holmes to get him to take
on that golf contract
or holmes thinking man i really
snookered sneed
to get jared goff and to get them to
give us extra trade assets
to take jared goff i wanted golf all
along
this is great i come out of this with
even more than i would have gotten for
matthew stafford
because i made them think i was taking
their garbage away
well i mean listen maybe that's the fact
of the matter but
you know i don't look at it either way
as one team
won or lost i think both teams got
really what they wanted
at the end of the day you know the lions
knew it was over with matthew stafford
they got a quarterback who's won and can
be a part of their culture or be a good
soldier jared goff is that there's no
doubt about that
whether we want to debate how he plays
on the field so hey they got their
starting quarterback
and they know their team has a lot of
holes and issues
and they need to rebuild it so now he's
got the draft picks to go along with it
for the rams
i think they're going to be able to look
at it and go wait you know we think our
team's really good
in fact we think if we had a better
quarterback you know that they think
they probably
might be playing this weekend i think
that's how the rams view themselves
and i think they look at it and go we're
in the window
we're in la we like the star power thing
and i think mcvay and les snead will
just go wait we got our stars
okay and now we'll fill in you know the
other positions of need oh wait
offensive line okay we don't need blue
chippers sean mcveigh's really good at
coaching that part he'll hide some of
the deficiencies there
oh we'll get a darius williams you know
in the third or fourth round of the
draft things like that
and they seem to be content building
their team that way so i really think it
is a win-win though
at least the way i look at it mike on
this one
well it's a win-win to get the
transaction accomplished whether it's a
win-win moving forward is a different
issue but from the standpoint of the
immediate problem
that the two teams had the lions need to
get maximum value for stafford
and they need a quarterback to take over
at least in the short
term and the rams need to get rid of
goff and upgrade at the quarterback
position
on paper win win whether or not
both teams win we'll see and there is
one game they'll play
in 2021 where both can't win it's going
to be lions
at rams at some point this season a game
that you otherwise would look at and go
now you look at it you say put that one
in prime time baby let's see goff versus
stafford and hopefully early in the
season before either of them may get
injured and i'm not
not trying to i'm not trying to put the
uh the jinx on them i'm just saying you
know
you don't want to bury it in november or
december because you never know the
world changes a lot by the time you get
late in the season as it relates to the
rams one thing that hasn't changed their
draft philosophy
they they opt for the scratch instead of
the pick they want
the guy who is proven and they're
willing to give up those first round
picks
they will have gone unless they go out
and trade for someone else's first
rounder which based on their habit of
trading
away first rounders is unlikely 2017
2018 2019 2020
21 22 23
with no first round
pick their last first round pick was the
guy they just dumped onto the lions
in jared goff that to me
is amazing and you know what i got a
theory that just popped into my head
remember when they got all those picks
from washington
for robert griffin iii and at one point
les
need wrote on a whiteboard somewhere
something along the lines of dominate
with washington's picks
right and they made a big deal about
well you know what when you go back and
look at what they got
they didn't do crap they didn't nominate
they won that trade they didn't dominate
with those picks
and that may have developed for less
need an aversion
to using any first-round picks because
you know what happens
when you use a first-round pick you open
yourself up to criticism that you pick
the wrong guy
and then you have to spend the next
three or four years hoping that the guy
develops because if he doesn't
you look like an idiot for using that
first round pick so
if you can swap that first round pick
for a proven player
number one you never get criticized for
making a first round pick
that ends up blowing up in your face and
number two hey
we got him bran we brought brandon cooks
he's a proven commodity we got jalen
ramsey yeah it took two first one picks
but he's a proven commodity
robert woods was a free agent they
signed but but the point is you're right
you know
we're we're unloading we're unloading
we're unloading
first round picks we're using free
agency
and trades to get proven commodities
but we're never putting ourselves out
there
right the rams are the team that is
afraid to dance for fear of being
criticized for their moves
they won't put themselves out there
drafting first-round picks
because they don't want to be criticized
for drafting their own guys i mean
at a certain point when you go that many
years without a first round pick
you you you come to the conclusion this
team just doesn't want to use first
round picks chris
yeah no mike i mean i think you hit on
it i think they're into the proven
commodity
you know world of building a football
team and and and two
you know again the other thing i'll just
say because
the guy you know is a carbon copy of a
coach i was with for a long time
sean mcvay i don't think they have the
patience for the young guys sometimes
you know i think they look at it and go
wait our team's ready right now
i don't want to you know have to take a
step back to wait
two years for young guys to develop and
do things like that
so i think they're a little you know
anti that approach to a degree
and i think they look at it and just
like the graphic we showed of some of
their first picks the last few years
i mean yeah they're second and third
round picks but they're good
i mean these players contribute to their
football team they're players
gerald everett nope boom rap acres
they're all in there
playing contributing to that football
team let alone they got other guys
down the line who are really damn good
too so la i think fuels lesnin and mcvay
feel comfortable about their ability
to get bargain draft picks guys that'll
contribute to their team
in the middle rounds and i think they
like their ability in evaluating free
agents and doing that and they've
they've
not you can't really argue it at this
point you really can't
i mean since they've been there hey
they've been about as relevant as any
team in football except for maybe you
know the patriots
so that it's been impressive and it's
working to this point so we'll see where
it goes from here
they have embraced the concept of year
to year life in the nfl where every team
is dramatically different and you don't
have
that nucleus of young talent that
develops
and grows over time that's what happens
when you don't use first round picks
you end up sacrificing the ability to
have a group of guys
who will work together grow together
achieve together succeed together and be
part of the team into the future
now look that that's no that's no
guarantee either i mean minnesota's
followed that approach for the last 10
or 15 years and what does it want them
at least the rams have been to a super
bowl
but um you put a lot in
your effort every year to go out and
improve
and if you fail in any one year it could
all fall apart
and then you're left with a franchise in
shambles that's the challenge chris you
put more
more stock in your ability to make good
free agent moves and good trades
when you're not taking the young cheap
guy that you would develop over time and
maybe you're hitting the nail on the
head they just don't want to develop
young players
like john gruden didn't want to develop
young quarterbacks he didn't want to
mess with you he'd rather brought in a
veteran you don't want to teach
his kid who's wet behind the ears and
not wise beyond his ears
to learn how to play quarterback he
wants somebody who knows how to do it
like a rich gannon
no definitely i mean that and that
really went for all positions it wasn't
just quarterbacks it was you know
he made comments all the time like that
well i don't want to get a rookie here
when i can get a seventh or eighth year
guy and we can hit the ground running
and going and we don't have to wait for
this rookie to fill in at right guard
and
you know wait to him to catch up i think
there is certainly
an aspect of that and i think the other
aspect that allows them at least to play
this type of game to what you're
mentioning
the free agents the proven commodities
the middle round draft picks
the not building a team right like that
comes together like you're saying that's
a bunch of young guys
see the one thing they have that's the
ability to do that
is mcveigh because of his ability to
communicate and bring the guys together
and be so
good in the camaraderie department and
talking to guys
you know he can bring a team together
maybe quicker than some other coaches in
football can
because that is a special aspect of what
he brings to the table
and because of that yeah they can
probably uh flirt with this kind of team
building
maybe more than other teams out there
well jared goff trades in the kind of
team building that
clearly had made him not part of the
team in la for some good old-fashioned
kneecap biting with the detroit lions
and
coach dan campbell how will goff do
biting kneecaps as he's getting up off
the
turf at ford field hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports